(groovy music)
- Sit down.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Wow, hi.
- Have you ever met Ernie?
- I have not had the pleasure.
- No, we haven't.
Yeah.
- Hi.
- Oh.
- Pleasure's mine.
- Well, look, look at this.
You did it right now.
- I'm just making sure I'm not...
- Oh, get it together.
Yeah, no, we gotta keep all
our kibbles in business here.
We wanna make sure they ask us back.
(audience laughing)
- (chuckles) Yeah, that's the only reason
I'm turning away from you.
That's the only reason.
- No, it's fine, it's fine.
I totally get it.
- No, no, no, we understand it.
But Ernie and I were talking
New Year's resolutions.
What you got, girl?
- Oh, I'm terrible with
New Year's resolutions.
I try to make them and then
I never keep them, ever,
except for twice, the first
time I moved out to LA,
and this year's New Year's resolution,
which is to move to New York.
So I'm moving to New York.
So these are the only two ones
that I've ever-
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah.
- So you got a little
traveling spirit on you.
I like it.
- Yeah, just a little.
- I like it.
- Yeah.
- So when you shoot the
show, "Emily in Paris",
are you guys actually
filming there in Paris?
- Yeah, in Paris.
- Talk about it.
- It's incredible.
- Yeah, I know. I hadn't...
I'd been once with, like, a
school trip, when I was 16,
and I don't remember anything.
And then, now, all summer
long, we were shooting.
So I would fly back and
forth for a few days,
and I'd have all this time off,
and I'd, "Look, the Eiffel
Tower selfie," you know?
(everyone laughing)
And it was so cool.
It was awesome, yeah.
- One of your first big roles
was in "Guardians of the Galaxy".
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yeah.
- It's a crowd-pleaser,
that one, yeah. (chuckles)
- Do you get recognized for that role?
- Mercifully not, because
I was bright pink,
head to toe, with yellow eyes.
So hopefully people don't
look at me and be like,
"Oh yeah, that's that alien."
(audience laughing)
- Well-
- But yeah, there was one time
at the airport I was a mess.
I was going to Mexico with my mom,
and I had the biggest zit in
the middle of my forehead.
It was like a unicorn, like...
(audience laughing)
And that was the time that
somebody was right in front
and they kept stealing glances.
And I kept doing this.
And I think they think
that I was being like,
"Don't look at me," but
what I was doing is,
"Oh God, this is such a big
zit," you know? (laughs)
(audience laughing)
They must be looking at the zit.
So they eventually were like,
"Were you in 'Guardians of the...'"
I was like, "Oh, yes, yes."
So I think "Ah, you're
not looking at my zit."
- "I thought you were looking
at this big thing right here.
No, yes, 'Guardians'.
That was me."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"Guardians."
(audience applauds)
(laughs). Yeah.
And your character is so
iconic on "Ghostbusters".
Do you get...
Do people send you photos
dressed like the character?
- Yeah, no, I get photos,
people with tattoos.
I went to buy a car,
and the mechanic there
had my face tattooed
on his leg.
- (gasps) Wow.
- And I was complimented by that, I think.
(everyone laughs)
You know, but yeah, no,
"Ghostbusters" is quite a phenomenon
all over the world,
and I'm so, so thankful
to be a part of that, as
"Guardians", I'm sure.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's really fun.
- Well, I think I mostly
get people dressing up
like the cast of "Reno 911".
- Yeah (laughs).
(audience cheers and applauds)
Thank God I wasn't the
one in the booty shorts,
'cause that would've been a problem.